Vsauce you're probably checking out my
clip-on flip-up shades of thinking to
yourself WTF which is exactly what we're
talking about today these houses covered
video game WTF twice already but we only
barely scratch the surface so without
further ado get ready for more
Vsauce WTF first stop the age-old
question where do babies come from in
Minecraft you might think it's based on
spawn timers or in some cases hot fixes
or hatches but no apparently they do it
the old-fashioned way speaking of
amazing feats of strength check out
spider-man's dive into the ocean ah the
forum excellent
oops grand theft auto san andreas gives
us the opposite of a faceplant it's
important to open your parachute early
before you die unless of course you
never stop falling
this one's famous a guy pushes a goat
and forces it to climb a ladder but
what's famous about the clip isn't the
goat it's the guys laughs and yes you're
reading that correctly his laugh about
that one glitch lasts for more than nine
minutes whoa hey hey hey hey
my druids not leveled high enough for me
to test this so I don't know if they
fixed it yet but if you switch to flight
form and then join a dungeon that you
can mount it like oculus mount and then
immediately leave the dungeon boom you
are in flight form and mountain
[Music]
Age of Conan has some pretty girls but
part of this girl's body seems possessed
in that good way watch closely
if you like you're twitching less subtle
check out this guy from stalker or if
you want it more deliberate check out
this thing players can customise the
pitching stance and the windup and it
looks like the sky's the limit
here's my favorite dancing dancing
dancing [ __ ] remember game genie well
this guy found a code that makes
everything act like a hammer brother but
in conclusion here's something that is
the most annoying when reality stops
working
luckily he does finally come to rest on
the ground just kidding it gets weirder
we've got way more Vsauce video game WTF
coming soon but in the meantime tell me
in the comments below what was the last
thing that made you say WTF can't wait
to hear them and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]